I'm attorney I graduated from the
University of Chicago Law School in 1964
I've been practicing lawyer since then
and on a member of the bar of the state
of New York and of the District of
Columbia I specialized in the 1970s in
the military law practice military law
in Asia Europe and later became the
editor in chief of the military war
reporter in Washington for a number of
years and in the 70s and 80s I was staff
counsel of the scent of constitutional
rights in New York City I also in the
late 90s was a adjunct professor at John
Jay College of Criminal Justice the
University of York write 12 courses on
propaganda and disinformation have you
also been involved in journalism been
published yes I have a since 1977 78 in
addition to being a practicing lawyer
I've also been a journalist and a
publisher writer specializing in
intelligence related matters and
particularly their relationship to the
media for more than 20 years I've been
co-publisher of a magazine
called the covert action quarterly which
particularly deals with the reporting on
intelligence agencies primarily US
agencies but also armed I published
magazine for number of years Cole lives
of our times which specifically was a
magazine about propaganda and
disinformation and I've been the
managing director of the Institute for
media houses for a number of years I
also for about 20 years ago I think was
one of the principals in a publishing
company called Sheridan Square press
that published books and pamphlets
relating to intelligence and media you
also write you author yes I do have
written Oh dozens of articles on
particularly on on media and
intelligence
I edited about seven or eight books on
the subject I contributed sections to a
number of other books and had many of
our articles of course have been
appeared in I own our own publications
but I've also had artists teetering
around the world including
New York Times Washington Post and major
media like let those appear a lot on
radio and television as an expert on non
intelligence in the media slowing down
of it now isn't getting older I used to
do a lot of speaking at universities and
colleges around the country and debating
government officials and people
connected with organizations that
supported the CIA or the FBI and other
intelligence agencies testified as an
expert witness in the area of
governmental use of media for
disinformation and Ron Campbell yes I
have I've testified as an expert in that
field in both state and federal courts
of this country I testified in foreign
courts I testified was before the United
Nations on that subject and once before
the US Commerce Callanetics 20 would
copy of a you all see is a summary of
your permit actors yes that's the best
my CD that I prepared probably
CV and accepted as an expert witness for
the issues of information
the shot of the course over a third
automatic native the same user commedia
by government aids yes I have I've made
many government reports on subject
anybody here you give the court a very a
brief summary of the subject indicating
the extent to which this type of
activity by government still take part
yes I can my book is in ancient history
but it should be noted that that
governments around the world have
secretly used the media for their
purposes for many hundreds of years
probably thousands but certainly from
the 16th and 17th century there's been
plenty of this personality used by
governments a secret use of the media or
for our purposes though the particularly
relating to the u.s. the most
significant to the first major
deliberate program in this country was
during World War one when President
Wilson saw an organization called the
committee for Public Information under a
public relations executive man named
George creel the purpose of this
committee was to propaganda the war
effort against Germany this was created
immediately after the u.s. entered World
War one 1917 and in propagandizing war
effort war news it was the policy of
this committee to have no compunctions
about falsifying the news whenever it
was felt that that was necessary to help
the war it can you give us an example
the type of falsification
talking about yes they the Committee for
public information purported very often
to release documents supposedly Kenyan
documents to the press in order to
substantiate whatever particular
position the the most of the government
had been taken at the time you want the
most famous that happened early that's
its creation in 1917 was a
disinformation campaign to suggest that
the Russian revolutionaries Lenin in
particular and Trotsky were actually
German agents being paid by the Kaiser
the government and creoles committee
made up the story they made up created
phony documents they passed it all to
friends in the major newspapers and
almost immediately this was front-page
news around the United States and around
the world
I'm going to show you one New York Times
headline era that's the kind of
falsification you're talking about yes
this is the rest of the taxes from an
article where where that headline
appeared but that was on the front page
of the New York Times in 1917 and later
it transpired that the documents were
reporters that have been created by mr.
creel and of course this was obvious by
the current course of history the
Russian revolutionaries were hardly
friends of the Kaiser it's much less
employees can you continue with your
something yes after World War one the
u.s. continued to be the or actually
became the world's leader in the control
of information Britain had been more
preeminent before World War one but a
bit at the end of the what you
was really in control of old-world
communication media and disinformation
was used by the government sporadically
going to be interwar years was
particularly used in the red scares of
the 1920s and the creation of
disinformation suggesting various
components of the government work were
communists but it wasn't a major aspect
of government policy until the advent of
World War two and that was when
deliberate disinformation or a structure
for for committing deliberate
disinformation became very very
important what happened at that point in
history to bring about well at the very
beginning of World War two there were
really two schools of thought
competing both of which had government
agencies one that was set up was called
the the office of War Information which
was a civilian organizational over
closely with the with the War Department
as it was then called and it was headed
by a man named Elmer Davis who was very
famous reporter of journalism
his philosophy was that the agencies
should tell the American people exactly
what was happening tell them the truth
if if we lost the battle somewhere in
Europe and the Pacific we should tell
the people we lost that battle one about
will be Tommy why but he believed that
in the long run we would do best by
reporting the truth but at the same time
another key organization of developed or
Rhodes who was the Office of Strategic
Services the OSS which was headed by a
military man Donovan who was known as
Wild Bill Donovan who believed the same
that George creel had at his philosophy
from World War one which was that you
should lie to the people whenever it's
necessary but never to think lying will
help maintain morale and went to war
this struggle was was taking place of
course in the context World War two
and Donovan won both with President
Roosevelt and afterward with President
Truman his philosophy that that
disinformation was a powerful valuable
weapon for a country to have and that
the disadvantages of lying to the
American people were outweighed by the
advantages of being able to manipulate
the media so when the war was over the
office of War Information was dissolved
the OSS was transformed into the CIA and
the CIA was now existing in peacetime my
new world war 2 was over and now the CIA
is set up with this information as a
major part of its work and in fact as
mostly supports later pointed out the
largest single part of the CIA's
operation the within the government
least the acceptability of line to the
public became very widespread and
acceptable even in time of peace there
had been people who felt well it's one
thing when you're at war but even in
time the peace that he came acceptable
and it spread from other agents
including the FBI which also began to
engage in media manipulation in a very
very large way so in addition to being a
wartime strategy perspective the
security of the nation the propagation
of falsehoods
in times of war this tactic started to
use in East on exactly that was the
major difference certain things were
much more acceptable or expected over
the course history in time of war and
were generally supposed to stop what the
war was over now there were people who
argue in the late 40s that the Cold War
was was a war just like a hot war and
that was the war that was on and that
was why I got to do this but what really
happened is there were not battles being
waged between soldiers it was not a hot
war going on anywhere and yet the
infrastructure that had been set up to
spread this information to be able to
lie became institutionalized and became
operating rate the greater level how is
it that some individuals like yourself
have become more aware of these kinds of
practices in our lifetime often mass of
the population as not well it's mostly
because by coincidence there were a
number of factors that came together
mostly in the 1970s leading to major
congressional investigations of these
activities leading some newspapers to
fun seriously
best native reports and in the middle of
mid 70s there were series series of
congressional reports on intelligence
activities a whole section of which was
devoted to de media activities and then
there were major expose in the New York
Times in the Washington Post it was sort
of the Watergate mentality I guess that
allowed this to happen there was a
window of a few years when exposing
government misconduct particularly past
government misconduct and sorrowful
governor's and certainly older better
but at least there was a window of
opportunity where this was acceptable
even within the mainstream the
establishment press was not frowned upon
as much as it might have been at other
times both or and since before we go
into some specific instances in detail
and explain the court that really how
does this information work why is it so
it's what is it so successful well I get
that is in firstly the target of
propaganda disinformation the consumer
of the false news so speed is what we're
talking about is the American public in
general and sometimes the public or
overseas
disinformation is almost always by I
have Nisshin about things that the
average person has no separate personal
knowledge of otherwise it couldn't
really work I mean you can't fool the
people you're talking about you can fool
the other people who don't know that
you're not trying to fool with people
talking about that the simplest example
is during the Vietnam War when there was
a massive bombing campaign in the US was
bombing Cambodia President Nixon and
Secretary of State Kissinger repeatedly
made public statements that we are not
dropping bombs in Cambodia well you
couldn't fool the Cambodians who look up
and so the bombs fall in their backyard
a new
the comparative people by and large
accepted these statements as truth and
in fact that was a disinformation
campaign was later admit you're really
we're talking about things that the
public there's no separate knowledge of
and it's also reinforced by the fact
that the Americans generally tend to
believe what their government tells them
to believe that government officials and
all levels generally tell the truth and
that if you have that that absence of
skepticism is a major plus for the
disinformation is also it's very very
unusual around the world other than the
United States and most other countries
particularly in Europe it's much more
the opposite people tend on average to
be very skeptical of their community if
the Italian government issues a
statement average Italian on the street
will say it's probably a lot until you
can prove to me otherwise that it's not
like because governments lie that's what
they you know they sort expect them that
whereas Americans don't expect that the
average American can hear something from
the government your news on television
and assumes that what they're hearing is
the truth unless they're shown otherwise
they assume that almost nothing is ever
a conspiracy in Europe it's very much
the opposite anything happens they tend
to think it's a conspiracy unless you
show that they're busted conspiracy I
mean after all conspiracy just means you
know more than one person to be involved
in something and if you stop and think
about it almost everything
sniffing that happens everywhere
involves more than one person get here
there is not a bit really but there's
just an underlying assumption that most
things are not conspiracy and when you
have that it enables a government which
has a propaganda program as a
disinformation program to be relatively
successful in having its disinformation
acceptance the other reason why it might
works even though as we as we know
they're there somewhere there are people
who know it's not true somewhere they
know you're lying doesn't but another
reason it works is that this information
is very very effective over time the
longer that you where you are can
control the spin on the story the more
that spin becomes accepted as the
absolute truth and this company the
government has a great deal of power and
influence over that spin why is it so
effective
well this is an area where I had to
consult with other experts because it
turns out really to be a neurological
function and I was the first explained
to me by a professor at Harvard Medical
School and it has to do with the way the
human brain remembers things the way we
learn things the way we create patterns
and associations and reinforce what I
don't like it sort of like channels in
the brain that when certain things
trigger certain collateral thoughts and
when you associate one thing with
another over time just the mention of
the one brings the association of the
other
what does sometimes mean is that even
when something is later exposés alive if
it was accepted as the truth for a long
time oh sure of it is alive is not
believe it's in one year not never the
best example that you know in my field
is one that john stockwell reported on
he was a CIA officer in Angola for a
moment they were base the CIA station
was basically
connell and when the Cuban troops were
sent in to healthier illness quite the
South Africans during early mid 70s
the CIA's task was to try to discredit
the Cubans and do whatever it could to
make people around the world think it
was a terrible thing that the Cubans
were helping they involve stockwell's
group in
let's do something terrible say that
humans did and other guys say why don't
we say they're raping a Muslim women a
be a great thing this way the other guy
says terrific and they call in their
media certainly started sitting there at
their desk of the CIA officer they start
typing out these notes story about how a
group of human soldiers raped a bunch of
an old women some operation and then
they great story number two which is
that the villagers got in the sense and
decided they didn't want the Cubans
anymore I'm going to find the soldier
estimate Story number three the
villagers captured the Cubans or before
they were tried and by a jury of the
women victims and they were later
executed with their own weapons and they
made a series of about 12 newspaper
stories in a row and with one phone call
in one visit it went out of the wire
services if Wednesday Europe went into
the United States it went around the
world and for about a six-month period
there are all these stories about
horrible human rapes in Angola and what
that does is when you hear the average
person hears and grow up human they'll
think raped other women and if they hear
rate from women they'll think Angola
Cubans here Angola
they'll think humans rape of the winners
and these patterns build up so that that
becomes the truth and that in your mind
for years later john stockwell with the
CIA wrote a book exposing it wrote a big
op-ed piece in The New York Times
entire Cuba Angola started as a
fabrication and he sat there at the desk
typing it and the day after that started
here there was still 900 million people
around the world and 40 only story was
true because one year after year after
year you hear that something as the case
one story one day saying hey the whole
thing was a lie and and it doesn't
register on the brain you can't beat
those those patterns that has built up
let's go back now example let's go back
down to the general area of intelligence
because all this activity is useless
unless there's a structure into which it
fits in which going to go out do with
the kind of structure of media
operations puts out just on incidentally
how extensive yes we can be we have a
lot of information about the CIA we have
a certain amount of information about
the I a certain amount about military
intelligence where and the reason for
this is because there were those
congressional investigations that I
mentioned before there have been reports
published particularly from the Church
Committee in the late 70s where they
published volume after volume describing
extent of media operations by the CIA
and other agencies they the exact
amounts of money that would be extent
were were not divulged by those initial
reports because that was
to classify the intelligence budgets are
always classified except at the same
time every fuel need something newspaper
where they say the classified budget
which is approximately 25 million
dollars so our thoughts open so what we
probably learned from these reports is
that the first thing was that about 1/3
of the whole CIA budget went to to media
propaganda operation well a third of the
CIA a pleasure win through the media
propaganda operations how much would
that be proxy
we're talking about hundreds of millions
of dollars a year just for that I mean
the intelligence budget now everything
together is according to these all these
reports that say in secret but is about
25 to 30 billion dollars a year now a
lot of that is high-tech stuff I think
if you were going to talk about
satellites and so on but the stuff that
goes to the CIA is separate billion and
when you factor out overhead things like
that you've got an operational amount
most of the estimates suggest that that
hundreds of billions hundreds of
millions of dollars close to a billion
dollars
spend every year by the United States my
secret again now yeah being a fairly
good Venus will CIA because it at least
has been admitted in the past that they
did do this stuff they admit they do it
announce that they they said it on food
within the United States but they they
admit that that's part of what they do
the FBI is much harder to get figures
for because they don't generally to
conducting media operations and less
until something gets exposed and they
have to admit that particular operation
they deny to an extent where it's really
hard to try and estimate how much money
is being used by the FBI and by the
military intelligence agency but it's
sort of clear that that hundreds of
millions of dollars a year are being
spent by various aspects of the
government on deliberately creating and
spreading lies you when we get into the
specifics of the media operations
related to partner for King James little
ray can you give us the background and
give us some idea of the influence that
the CIA and the FBI had over the media
yes again this is something that very
specific figures came out in the 70s and
80s and we don't know the precise
figures today we have no reason to think
that that they are significantly less
than what came out but when the Church
Committee reported on CIA media
operation
for example beyond friends in the press
beyond having people who were just
generally bought along similar lines it
turned out that they had thousands of
journalists in their employ not not
nearly friend and not merely agents not
really someone who could pass a story to
the people who might have appeared to
the outside world to be a reporter for
CBS was in fact the CIA employee gave
salary in CIA and that was repeated
thousands of times all around the world
they also owned outright the CIA about
at that time about 250 or more media
organizations that's wire services
newspapers magazines radio TV stations
all around the world that they only
doubt that the actual shareholder of the
Company turned out to be some CIA fronts
she did not need very many of these
organizations because those that got
named of course I had to close down
immediately but it was learned that even
things like the Roman daily America
which is a major english-language
newspaper in Rome for 23 years that
their own bus
this was published and posting paper
closed the next day but most people
didn't realize the extent of the
intelligence media organization is
fairly incredible TBH they sort brag
about it when you read the books about
history CIA one of the heroes was the
first man in charge of media operations
man named Frank Wisner and they referred
to his organization as the Mighty
Wurlitzer this was image of this guy
sitting at one of the giant organs you
know with 17 organ chords he of playing
this look sort of like the Phantom of
the Opera enacted that scene and there
was the guy running the CIA VD
operations all around the world and he
really was because he every single city
of any size on earth he had some
employee who was supposedly worked for
those paper or max
or wire suits and they could get stories
beware I think I've just wanted to for
specific economy yeah there was one
actually the novel was published written
by a former CIA officer named James
hotel who was not in the propaganda
nation he was in finance but he was so
amazed wrote a lot about this he was in
the nation of Japan one time there's a
big debate raging there or whether
nuclear-powered ships should be allowed
to talk in Japanese ports was a very
always be a touchy issue be since their
achievements and very touchy issue in
Japan even peaceful uses women for the
power and the u.s. line was to promote
our ships because some of us had
homework them so they wanted the
Japanese papers to editorialize in favor
of this debate was going on Jim said he
looked and so this guy down there by
this sit down and type this is a CIA
officer employed in the US government
type and editorial and then waved
goodbye to everybody left the office the
next morning that appeared as the
editorial the lead editorial team the
largest newspaper in Japan now that they
didn't go to a friendly publishers AG
who sort of like maybe do something a
little bit favorable to decision they
wrote it or they handed it to the guy
the next day in Japanese and Peter's in
the paper
another thing shown the influence here
in this country
Plus during the Vietnam War I know some
people like people like
there was a Life magazine that had a
cover picture of a North Vietnamese
stamp that showed the enemy shooting
down American planes and showed us
planes because markings in burst of
flames and crashing and us pilots be
killed and it was a pretty bizarre and
gruesome set of postage stamps and it
was a whole story in there basically
trying to give the line the enemy's
glorifying the killing of Americans and
they thought it was so great to to kill
Americans that they were putting it on
their postage stamps the only thing that
was later learned is at least were not
North Vietnamese stamps they were CIA
forgeries had never been real stamps and
the CIA was able to have them appear on
the cover of Life magazine as if they
were the real thing that level of
influence is something that many people
don't realize it then when you read the
congressional reports agent opinion of
the page is absolutely astonishing out
given the urgency and given that they
had hundreds of millions of dollars of
every man they can get almost anything
to appear almost anywhere or about the
FBI
well the FBI there's much less
documentation again because the official
position was that the FBI doesn't do
this there are official positions of CIA
doesn't with all they tried not to talk
about it but what did come out in the
congressional reports primarily is that
a major FBI division was called the
crime reporting division was
theoretically supposed to keep track of
how federal crimes were being reported
why that was there
that's what the spiracles but in fact
what it was doing was a whole division
set up to keep track of journalists and
reporters and magazines and newspapers
to decide who could be counted on to
write stories that the FBI wanted
written who would slant stories the way
they wanted it the the question of
whether these particular reporters were
actually FBI employees like like so many
CIA employees is unclear that's never
been admitted by the government that the
FBI actually secrets on employees and
had them hid a job as a correspondent on
a newspaper that's and whereas we
noticed CIA to that many places there's
no reason to think they couldn't have
done it other than the fact that it
hasn't yet been been exposed but in any
event there were significant pressures
available to the FBI to use their
friends and the Church Committee report
gives there's many many examples are
copies of memos Hoover on down where the
via the attachments that get this
information to our friends at the code
we News Service get this information to
our friends that digest were friendly AP
reporters and an inner posting each
other
flipping indicating that that someone
had God
and the wire so here in stories let's
turn it out to the use of the media in
this type of campaign activity against
Martin Luther King jr. before you do
that you teleported here as one of the
sources of underlying their testimony
this afternoon yes I guess the amount of
additional research and preparation in
contemplation of appearing here they're
really of two main sources the first of
course is the various congressional
reports that we talked about in addition
to reports about general operations or
misconduct of the CIA to the FBI they
have been specific studies I will take
attention in this case but they have
been specific studies related to Martin
Luther King jr. both with respect to tax
on him while he was alive and also
specific reports with respect his murder
there was an entire volume published
from one of the Senate investigations
the FBI media campaign against dr. King
and there was a House committee that
published a volume of investigating
assassination and these of course are
the most important sources or what I'm
talking about whether people are written
about because they have a great deal of
government documentation in
which no private journalists could ever
get the hands on there are things in
there that even the best research
wouldn't be able to obtain that the
congressional committees that subpoena
policy and were able to amass thousands
of documents most of which were
photocopied and attached to their
reports for our purposes here as well as
those what other sources have you use
well I've also of course reviewed many
books that have been written on a
subject hundreds of articles briefcases
full of clippings that were major
stories written about dr. King
particularly in the last few years life
and then the most of the coverage of the
first few years of the dr. James Earl
Ray case before and after is guilty plea
over intensive coverage as you can
imagine and throughout the 60s and early
70s it was quite a bit of coverage Ghost
clippings that I can able
you some of the sporadic coverage in the
eighties and nineties have also been
able to assemble and review although the
level of that coverage system has
increased very much of the last decade
or so reports would you summarize your
sometimes project congressional reports
tell us about the the FBI is used to be
in general but that particularly hasn't
really started King well in general the
first thing they show is that throughout
its history the FBI has made relations
with the media a key area not so much
infiltrating employees as the CIA did
but cultivating very very deep
connections throughout the American
means that they had the entire division
of the FBI that crime reporting division
was dealing solely with developing
friendly journalists developing ways in
which you could get what you wanted to
appear in the papers to be there but you
didn't want not to be there on a level
that was nobody realized until these
these reports came out yeah the crime
reporting division was keeping track of
version every journalist in America that
wrote anything that had to do with the
FBI and whether everything's been
classified as friendly or unfriendly of
course somewhat complicated as a general
event DJ it or who were like what they
wrote or not playing what they wrote
practically no opinion of nobody else
mattered while Hoover was alive but he
kept charts on every significant
journalist as to who was helpful when
you look through there were boards in
the documents come out you see
statements by Hoover an and his
immediate subordinates get this
information to print D terminals get
this to our friend at the US News &
World Report get this to some friendly
reporters in Memphis you just see all
that sort of stuff interesting we go
this infirmity never mattered whether
the information was true or false that
was not what it was about you find FBI
planting information that's true you
find them planting information it's
false the critical thing was if they had
the friend that media place that friend
was going to run with the client without
investing could you just cut through
tell us what the Church Committee said
about puntal Pro reports and explain to
the
for the continent opinion but their
hotel Provost was counterintelligence
program that was the major FBI program
to counter what it conceived to be
threats to American democracy and it was
at least in my opinion rather paranoid
well considered threats
it had visions trying to operate against
communists and socialists against New
Left against the old that against the
what they referred to as as black
nationalist what they refer to as eight
groups they had seven section just on
the patient of Islam they had a separate
section civil rights movement they had a
hybrid program on coming fill which was
to deal with the possibility of
Communists were infiltrating
non-communist there one section trying
to disrupt groups they helped economists
influence or dangerous and another one
trying to infiltrate groups or find out
about groups that they thought other
people trading basically they and
anybody have to understand that you
can't counterintelligence program is
really a misnomer because
counterintelligence normally but what
you're trying to
things out counterintelligence officers
in wartime and espionage just supposed
to be finding out information that these
were active committees not passive in
what counterintelligence programs were
were overt attempt sometimes very very
complicated operations disrupt
organizations which they felt for a
threat regardless of whether the
organization's were committing any
crimes and that the irony of this is
that
well the FBI theoretically was supposed
to limit itself to investigating crimes
and federal crimes of that it basically
took the position that you know thinking
bad boss was a primary didn't like the
current government of that day that was
a crime and if Google decided the route
should be disrupted then COINTELPRO
would sit down and figure out how to
disrupt it limit occupy in this
constellation today how do they regarded
him how was he hard well he was just
about the top of the list in terms of
who referred for reasons that are still
unclear many books have been written
about you
any quite understands what made the tip
he hated doctor killed he made no bones
about it he said he would send letters
using who's referring to him his garbage
referring to have a slide refer to he he
when Martin Luther King was was the
Nobel Peace Prize about this long
diatribe I have that as much because
they never his life can't back started
the whole program to try and this one
Peace Prize the program but he and the
SCLC as it does dr. King's organization
work were by themselves a major target
at the FBI from early on he certainly
was being investigated in the 50s
I learned until the early 60s that
really intensified but it was much more
public about dr. Kington almost any
other individual he would be public
about the Communists or terrorists or
whatever but Martin Luther King
specifically used use the most
horrendous languages right and once when
the only time he ever gave a press until
be recalled in Rome I move became the
most notorious liar in the history of
the United States he was saying that
because King had had the temerity to say
that FBI agents
being terribly helpful to blacks who
having problems with racism and you can
you give an example it's going to be the
operations behind the rocket sure the
first really significant ones were to to
suggest that Sony Christian Leadership
Conference was was a communist
infiltrated and communist dominated they
the FBI had prepared dossiers on King
you know everybody was working with them
and had two people who were close to dr.
King had at some time in the past and
some affiliations with communist you
should understand because this came out
later they had no evidence whatsoever
that either of these two people was at
that time economists or that either
these two people was trying to impose
some conscious line on dr. King but they
decided to say that anyway and they
prepared dossiers on these two one was
up one was a white lawyer Stan Levinson
hills of black organizing named Jack
Waddell and what they did is they the
same white get us a friend that this
paper gets a friend there they started
planting stories
let me give you
one of the putting couldn't crawl up on
the stand books or tree from the stories
that they London Atlas Nestle second
page I think they had one this right
this was a major story about death and
an attempt to mean they were attempting
to discredit dr. King and the
organization they're not they're not
trying to just get rid of Dell because
that was better for the organization but
they spread this this particular
clipping that leaves something that
constitutional but it says in it that
that makes reference to prior articles
in the settlers globe-democrat
or oftentimes picking the story which
was essentially based on the FBI
spreading this information appeared all
over the country general attack is there
anything anything else in difficut about
well actually this is a good one because
it demonstrates some of the techniques
they use the most significant one is
being fuzzy whenever you can it has in
there it it taught it refers to a veil
and says has been identified as a member
of the National Committee of the
Communist Party and that this this is
the sort of the passive tends to avoid
saying what what what you know when you
say someone has been I don't say who
identified you don't even say whether
this identification well say whether
it's true or false I mean you know one
person anywhere can say something about
anybody then you say he has been
identified as such and such that's very
important particularly because we that's
in the present tense it says has been
identified as a member of the Khans body
we know now that at the time when the
FBI gave this information and they knew
that was untrue because they knew
whatever might have been ten years
before they knew at that time that he
was not a member of the Communist Party
and yet they sent this informations idea
it's part this is a part of a broader
effort on the part of the FBI to
discredit the black movement and tie the
civil rights movement very much so it
was one of the few instances where we
were actually testified before Congress
and allow the testimony the Republic he
the line was that that the black
movement that civil rights movement was
being exploited by communists and this
particular clipping is another example
against unfair times of this program
these are all despite the fact that many
of my lines oh this one is not my mind
these are all based on material gets
prospectus almost that were prepared to
FBI and given to their dear friends in
these in these stories and in this case
it's even more significant because this
was part of a campaign oh so organized
that Hoover got his friends to write
stories about it before his testimony
became public so that when the testimony
then became public as he did with this
one people would know about it one of
his very very close friends was Joseph
Alsop it was a syndicated national
columnist back and this was else ups the
column about
terribly sad fact in America was totally
deprived economies this again was based
on whatever the FBI handed policies
which is one week before being other
story where the where the testimony
became public well there's an estimate
was an escalating pilot between Hoover's
FBI and Martin Luther King's SCLC and
civil rights and then I need more
activities what how did it intensify
from that would have been operated you
get started well the first real
escalation was sixty in late 64 when I
mentioned before the Hoover a press
conference enclosed a most notorious
liar country this was sort of a shock it
was shocking the extended to the
shocking instead of the Continental
public meeting with journalists and it
appeared all over the country the whole
conference was reprinted in US News and
World Report with a and taped in fact
the tape is originally using this is one
of the things that being the house to be
found
most outrageous in an attempt to try and
drive dr. Kington suicide shortly before
he went to get the Nobel Prize
the tape was mailed to him with a long
letter basically saying if you don't
kill yourself we're gonna make this
public nothing ever happened because he
was getting so much mail at this thing
if somebody thought was somebody had
tape up by his speeches and they put in
the back room they didn't get to look at
it until about nine months later all you
have to come back and then they saw be
it the dope trying to get it suicide and
then ten years later the FBI who wrote
that who made that tape and mail to the
dr. Chynn government influenced and
control console he print audio-visual
media and how that infrastructure gets
focused on opponents of the United
States such as part of the King do you
see how this incredible power was
brought against dr. King and intensified
against him during a lot gear yes I
think the main reason for that was very
very specific there was one speech that
dr. King gave in April of 1967 at
Riverside Church in New York City he
came out against the war in Vietnam and
remember back to that period of time
this was fundamental to being ripping
every aspect of this country the pros
and cons of the involvement in Vietnam
and when dr. King came out against the
US involvement there this was
immediately accepted by Jo Hoover as
proof that he was a communist proof a
terrible person unifying all of the
forces on the intelligence force of the
United States and so economists was not
just an FBI map and seemed to spread the
military intelligence intelligence other
absolutely once dr. King made that
statement the CIA in particular
considered him and his movement fair
game even to the extent that their
operations were limited to foreign
policy again because of the
congressional investigations I know that
the CIA which people thought did not
operate domestically in the US had a
huge domestic program called Operation
chaos which was designed to counter
opposition the Vietnam War
and even though they later admitted it
was illegal and later admitted they
issue doing it there in all books the
Congressional reports about all the
operation chaos activity in the United
States
and what they call black nationalist was
a specific target of that that campaign
this continues in 1968 and his activity
workers right near Memphis and then fine
for poor people any apartment
absolutely the campaign against dr.
King's activities went up to the very
last day of his life in particular on
the his involvement with the strike in
Memphis the FBI decided at that point to
try to spread stories that he was
encouraging violence one of the key
articles was in the Christian Science
Monitor the end of March of 68 and again
gives all of the themes that the FBI
wanted wanted planted particularly about
violence in the article uses bizarre
language for something about a small
strike in a medium-sized town that was
something but was not not not the first
shaking event this was a sanitation
workers strike in this story first one
has a potentially cataclysmic racial
confrontation not quite World War three
but along that kind of language and the
stories that begin with here this is
just before dr. King was killed were for
suggesting that he was mostly
violent forces chef this court a furious
our testimony from a a for New York
Times reporter who was told by his
national editor assigned reporters in
this quarter notwithstanding held by
this naturally called sinneth go to
Memphis and nail dr. King those were the
words Geraldo used in this here is that
the kind of thing you're talking about
oh absolutely
Hoover was suppose you see from the
memos in the report it was what we don't
know a tendency was sending people out
everywhere to talk to all of their
friendly media contacts get King and
they would usually deliver packets of
information much the polls to be used as
part of the of the campaign they also
use a lot of very interesting tactics
you see in these stories a lot of fuzzy
having the story that's on the screen
for example as a sentence and at near
the end of our system many blacks have
mixed feelings about dr. King this is a
a teach-in journalism 101 not to use
sentences like there was me many planet
many everybody had mixed feelings about
anything if you want to do it you say
who has what what feelings but the whole
thing was to try to say he's he's
violence he's hanging around the violent
people and basically that that flaxen is
nothing shouldn't support it but what
was this operation life media blitz this
media disinformation campaign what was
it like after dr. Kane was killed
well one thing the
attempts to discredit dr. King to
particularly FBI attempts did not stop
after his death they continued to send
out their little dossiers and reports
and phony information to try and
discredit his memory they also in the
beginning when of course the assassin
had not yet been caught or rather no one
had to get caught in charge
assassination had to give the impression
that the FBI was doing a great job I
mean one of the criticisms that was
unavoidable was when Hoover had already
publicly attacked dr. King in all these
magazines and it said iron ore is the
worst problem facing the United States
basalt
it became a problem for the FBI then to
try and convince America that they were
doing everything in their power to
apprehend his killer and to do that they
had to pull out all stops and get all
their friendly columnist writing story a
story that they were doing everything
they put in and also subsequently try
and add to the stories that they were
convinced that James Earl Ray was the
home sess put up this article
the start relates to any other yeah this
is interesting for where it reveals
later this was a story that came out in
1975 it's actually interesting example
of Jackie Anderson criticizing the group
of people of moaning fails to mention he
was one at the time something to happen
he's uh often when columns decided here
though via the slate but he was
reporting at this time a ban on how the
FBI had waged the campaign against doc
bikini how he knew about it knew about
all these girls accusations that were
being being handed out it's all I mean
the story is only interesting because
why didn't he say it at the time his
ones first thought but at least at least
he made a breast of somebody he also was
able to explain it that a number of the
rumors about dr. King had been proven to
be not true but what he didn't know at
the time because the Congressional
report came out later that he didn't
know is that even the FBI at the time it
was spreading the stories of nineteen
was a lively with the story now the same
time they were trying to discredit dr.
King didn't spread his name after he was
killed they were trying to intense the
manhunt and the law enforcement work
during that time yeah oh not only
enhanced but use hyperbole that was
pretty bizarre oh of course you can
understand the pressures that were on
caught the Drew Pearson was a very close
friend of Hoover's had a nationally
syndicated column and wrote one
basically designed to try and kill the
rumors that that who drove us a trying
part because in my king and in it
Pearson says he is convinced that the
FBI is conducting perhaps the most
painstaking exhausting manhunt ever
before undertaken in the United States
why how he would know is beyond us but
that's clearly what Hoover told him to
say they also I don't have to cook in
here they also had another one they're
very close operatives Jeremiah O'Leary
who was then that the Washington star in
an article for The Reader's Digest and
he went he went running beyond Pearson
instead it was the greatest of cannot in
law enforcement history in the world so
he was now saying this wasn't only the
best the greatest man after Paris that
this man ever anywhere there there were
a whole CNN of course when Ray was
arrested then there was a spate of self
congratulatory columns done by the same
friendly FBI genre wonderful job they
had done many other aspects of this
coverage after dr. King's death for
putting media operations well there
certainly are in my opinion at this coin
once we get beyond the things that have
been congressional reports I'm drawing
my conclusions based on my own
experience and expertise but it
certainly seems clear that there were
media operating
around not only that the FBI had done
wonderful job but also on the campaign
that demonstrated that not only the
James already done it but that you'd
acted alone one of the possible
operation such Iraqis well there you see
in stories again by friends of the FBI
statements like it looks like the theory
that there was a conspiracy is untrue
the FBI has exploded the theory that
there was a conspiracy the even people
who had a wrist see they got caught a
little bit because of the beginning they
were planting stories that had
conspiracy I mean there was a story that
the FBI planted very beginning saying
that dr. King had been killed by the
husband by really husband a lover of his
now later at ten years later so it just
was infected they had made up the story
but then they was so stuck because if
you're saying that Ray was hired by
somebody else to do it that's a
conspiracy so then they had dropped that
story because mountain lion was there
wasn't another saying they they and the
same people isn't mentioned that story
and then later on denounced the the
generally prevalent fury death the
murder conspiracy without one yeah
one of the people who acquired the
original travelin theory even
particularly actually have to be guilty
it got there was no longer judicial
proceeding going on about which they can
feed the stories they wanted to they
still felt a compulsion to periodically
come up with stories that there was no
conspiracy there wasn't a plot on the
street being another one of these these
examples well this is the continuation
of the lone lone nut gun that many
people federated throughout the period
of Tory's incarcerated
absolutely never because ray assisted
virtually from the day of the plea that
there wasn't in spirit II they felt
compelled to to continue to plant
because of these stories they they went
on for a number of years very tense
level and then offense or development in
the first year after the plea of guilty
Anderson wrote a number of columns that
just wasn't any conspiracy max lurker
wrote column saying
Ray was the killer or this nine to the
community theory and when another
example of how they buzzing it was even
please there was a story on the
Washington Post which I think I've given
you a copy of where they said no
evidence of any plot jury is told now
that isn't really what the jury was told
when you read the story is that the
prosecution I'm not presenting any
evidence of a fly which is very
different from said of course they
didn't present any evidence that there
wasn't a plot either and yet if you look
at that headline it looks like something
has been said and done in court showing
the jurors it was know a lot that's not
what happened it wasn't it wasn't
discussed either way and they there was
a story that need the next week in
Washington Post where the title of the
story was Rea alone still talks of apply
which again at journalistically was
ridiculous because there were millions
upon millions of Americans talking about
whether there was a clock and the story
was you know try to create the
impression with that Jane James okay
we'll start in Japan was the only person
in America but they're not giving a plot
that campaign and in fact they then said
well what we really meant was is the
only person who's officially involved in
the proceedings and things that supply
everything else doesn't and even that
wasn't true because the next day there
was a story in the papers that the the
judge here the judge at the time judge
babbled wasn't sure and thought maybe
their inventor plot and it certainly
made it clear
Tennessee law further if co-conspirators
can hopper arrested or died today would
be subject to drop let me look at that
with the shot that's going to appear in
the New York Times over on the 17th of
November 1978 right at the time when the
motoring others are being questioned in
examining $24.00 Committee on Saturday
and that's why I can speak of an
investigation from every time by the
near time and the FTO and the selected
into an Alton Illinois bank robbery an
investigation which never took place
now in a case out of example was the
type of this information that one finds
in a trade public mind well absolutely
given the fact that subsequently it was
shown that they were not suspects in
that robbery it the first thing it means
is that the the reporter is saying some
things which had to have been simply fed
to him and not check
if you're saying something happened
which in fact very very basic journals
that would improve didn't happen
you are either doing it on your own
threats of his officials of extremely
unlikely or you're being asked to put a
spin on something that you know is going
to be coming out the again I mean I
don't know what happened in Alabama
Illinois but if as I understand this
from testimony it is clear that the
regulars will not suspect in that case
this story is clearly this information
because it designed for making appear
not only that they were suspects in that
case but that they did and to make it
appear that two investigations confirmed
that whereas since we know wasn't true
it's impossible in your investigation
let me ask you on filing there's no long
road how you regarding what is your
explanation for the fact that there has
been such little national media coverage
of these distraught and this evidence in
this
then here in the courtroom to the first
crowd ever we produce evidence of this
fascination what has happened here that
money bullet sir is not sounding but is
in fact totally silent almost Oh
but as we know silence can be definitely
this information is not only getting
sort of things to appear print is also
getting certain things not to appear I
mean the first the first thing I would
see as a way of explanation is the that
incredibly powerful effect of this
informational over a long period of time
that I mentioned before for thirty years
the official line has been the James
Earl Ray guilt Martin Luther King and he
did all by himself that's 30 years not
not nothing like the short period when
their line was that the Cubans raped the
over 20 years its James over a kill dr.
King did it all by himself and when that
is imprinted in the minds of the general
public the 30 years if somebody stood up
and confessed and he said I did it
write it and do what I did here's a
movie is a video showing me do it 99% of
people will believe him because it just
didn't click in the mind it would just
go right it couldn't be it's just the 80
powerful psychological effect over 30
years of disinformation it's been
imprinted on the brains of the public
something
be not only to the knowledge
psychological point you also saying from
neurological yes that's why I'm not a
doctor but I do what I understood is
that these brains patterns of thinking
our physical aspect of the human brain
that's how we develop patterns of
thought I would develop associations but
then of course in India the Mighty
Wurlitzer we talk about is still there
and still playing its tune and even
though you might think thirty years is a
long time that almost everybody who
might get in trouble is probably dead by
now that's that's not worse the people
obtain influence people make vast sums
of money through this propaganda those
people pass that influence on to others
they pass the money down the line all
that can be a brisk for a very very long
time there are there are documents from
the investigation of the assassination
of Abraham Lincoln that is still
classified now when he asked me why but
they were originally sealed for a
hundred years
and in 1965 President Lyndon Johnson
said well it's so close to the Kennedy
assassination do people read the Lincoln
documents it might make them think funny
things about Kennedy so he classified
them for another 15 minutes so now that
the green children of anybody around the
Lincoln's was around that hour-long kid
and these documents are still still
classified and we're talking today about
a case that's a hundred years more
immediate than Lincoln and the
establishment is still the step
thank you very much for joining the
society thank you
you